one of the big questions surrounding the
Michael Flynn scandal including his lies
to the FBI and his eventual indictment
for those lies is why was Michael Flynn
lying to begin with a former director of
the Defense Intelligence Agency the DIA
National Security Adviser major military
figure he knows the risks of lying to
the FBI why would he lie to the FBI was
it to cover misdeeds he already knew he
had participated in and he thought I
mean so deep I'll try to lie my way out
of it well maybe it's not really clear
that's the case though what if it's much
simpler what if Donald Trump directed
Michael Flynn to lie and Flynn did it
because for whatever reason he was loyal
to Donald Trump well there's a new NBC
news report that really suggests that
there's something there in terms of
being directed to lie by Trump that
Robert Moeller is looking into as part
of his special prosecutor investigation
now to be clear for all we know Michael
Flynn has already told Robert Muller he
lied because Trump told him to and it
just hasn't made been made public yet
right we don't know what Muller got out
of Flynn as part of this deal but the
NBC report is really pointing in that as
something that is of interest to Robert
Muller the NBC report which is a really
good in-depth report about the
investigation that Robert Muller is
conducting says that special prosecutor
Robert Muller quote appears to be
interested in whether Trump directed
Michael Flynn to lie to senior officials
including pence or the FBI and if so why
according to sources this is actually
the simplest explanation for Michael
Flynn's bizarre behavior and it accounts
for a number of strange events in the
Trump Flynn timeline we know that in
December of 2016
Michael Flynn told Russian ambassador
Sergei kis lyac Russia shouldn't
retaliate against the u.s. for Barack
Obama sanctions against them because as
soon as Trump is inaugurated Trump's
gonna do everything he can to undo those
sanctions that was in December in
January
Flynn denied ever having had that
conversation why
not only is it illegal to lie to the FBI
Russia would also know that Flynn was
lying since they spoke to him so it
gives Russia leverage it's a really
risky move why would Flynn do it another
example after the White House was told
that Michael Flynn is a major risk that
he's compromised it took them almost
three weeks to get Michael Flynn to step
down to effectively fire him force a
resignation
why if Donald Trump had told Michael
Flynn to lie to deny whenever necessary
it kind of explains why Michael Flynn
took these risks it explains why it took
so long to fire Michael Flynn after it
was known that he was compromised it
explains why Trump tried to get Comey to
end the Flynn investigation and may be
feeling like he told Flynn to lie and so
he's sort of responsible for the mess
that he's in Donald Trump said I've got
to try to get him out of this and I'm
gonna tell Comey to end this
investigation into Michael Flynn this is
the clearest possible path to Trump
obstruction of justice so far
it fits the circumstances way more
cleanly than lots of other speculation
so Trump telling Flynn to lie explains a
lot but what it doesn't explain and this
is kind of the the most bewildering part
to me why would someone like Michael
Flynn lie in a way that risks his entire
political life for someone like Donald
Trump who has shown no loyalty to
anybody was Trump just the useful idiot
for Flynn and for others who had
business deals they wanted to do with
Russia that depended on the easing of
those sanctions and they thought we'll
we'll all make a ton of money if Trump
is president and he'll be none the wiser
I don't know the answer here Pat but
that's the main question for me it would
be totally believable that Trump told
Flint a lie my question is why is Flint
so loyal to Trump well I think he's
being loyal to Trump because he's always
been a military guy but never quite at
the top right so he's always had someone
to be subservient to and I think this is
where you have to draw the line though
because if he's being asked to lie to
the FBI he should know better than
anyone else that he can't get away with
it and and so he would be someone who
knows the risks and he would be someone
that presumably would
not be so liable to be manipulated in
this way I don't know the answer and I
hope we find out and really good
reporting by NBC News on this if you
haven't read the report we're linking to
it and I encourage you to check it out
the video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership